que pasa que el parlamento
debe votar incluso en condiciones de
carreteras de emergencia en todo el
territorio del país por un mes i
tangos y piensa en una movilización
Delaware
los militari se lo reserva y como yo
Tengo anillos que el gobierno es
prepararse para un escenario es claro
Misma rusia dentro con su paja encuesta
deformar fiat entrar entrar ronal estos dos
republica marina en la confianza del auto
vastos aromas proclama el adelantamiento
corroborar sus golpes en el territorio
lidiando con calaveras y sí a google y
ir a provocación ir a 3 es
sido premiado en el cajón ruso por
nosotros para los grandes
subir vistas a es una invasión rusa
incluyendo cómo vivo el presidente joe
Biden
creo que no sé lo íbamos a saber
una gran virola de
total pero creo que un diem
local una versión de prueba de enel del
donbass no es andros obstáculos ahora
crisis
ahora pues a pasar
rusia para defenderse una semi marina ne
creo que clark y ukrania no no creen
Bing una operación ofensiva aunque vamos
lado la provocacion si es pasajera
cada morir suceder decirlo bombardero bombardear
aws
de pantalla de calavera crear ahora
señorita pero mantenga el interruptor dentro vendido
fuera vs la crisis el conflicto es
pasando es souldiers de
rai a los que tienen mucha tension en la hipoteca
nervioso porque al filial con el
petición que están preparando para no
tener clara una guerra pero clara
irán de clara promovió el
pacífico y el
solución diplomática
No
sin nombre militar la amamos hasta los 70
para Rusia
ser ser útil será severamente
militar yo leyendo el puro yo yo
ultimo punto conjunto consejo de eso si
tienes un marine para una escalada diplomática
rusia kido que despues del apoyo y el
diálogo
diplomático
busca el gubbio del de mis per acorde
ahora no hay formato para paliar
un acuerdo que debe ser sustentado este
cosa de forma diplomática sin embargo
proyecto propio cuarteto el
normandía reino unido ranier que pid y hosts
unir cruces s con el techo de la
normal para hablar
caricia paranoica santa que por fin
cosa cruzada de forma pacífica y clara
Eso
el oeste una esquina idol stanley am
disparar
para usar la diplomacia de los hackers
hablar es finalmente deca arriba arriba
dos soldados en el siglo mucho mas